everyone wants to be an anti-aging
doctor everyone wants to live longer
forever
I don't think aging a disease I think
testosterone dropping one percent
normally after a certain age is part of
aging that is natural it shouldn't be
viewed as a disease
but uh you're I don't know that
anybody's anti-aging
absolutely but they're anti-looking like
they're aging why
because we are um as an influencer young
man the sexiest doctor alive I I think
that we are that that is held up and
supposedly influencing us on how we
should look regardless of the fact that
they're looking at somebody in their 30s
or their 20s or whatever you were at
that age you know that's what somebody
wants to look like and you know I'm I'm
I haven't done any work and I won't do
any work but I understand you should
with your eyes
but anyway but that's a different issue
but
no because I do have an issue
it's not about looks my the the skin
it's hard for me to open my eyes when
I'm tired what apoptosis told you yep
what is that well it just means like one
eyelid does not open as high as the
other because but it's the skin above
it's the skin above my eye at night
sometimes it gets pretty and then I
can't even open my I can't open my so
it's a functional thing yeah not to look
younger but I think looking young
looking attractive is
um what we're sold and we're just sold
as a culture to look young and to look
attractive and if you look attractive
and you look young supposedly you'll be
happier and if you look young and you
look attractive you'll be more
successful so that just the um
the result of Aging takes away
whatever the perceived good look is
so it's the perception of others
that's our society I'm not I you know I
have a shaved head I don't have not
wearing Just For Men you know my beard
is white but I'm saying predominantly
that's how people I like there is an
industry for this and I'm not against
this industry existing I'm just saying
as a medical person I'm not getting into
that
because my idea is to keep your body
healthy and to help guide you through
life as healthy as possible but not to
change the way you look because it's
going to impact your health like I draw
a line there so you're a kid now really
but when your hair turns gray will you
uh my hair is great I have a lot of
Grace I used to die and then I gave up
right but see you were willing to put a
chemical
in your body but not for your look but
not medically
I I did not think but you affect
yourself sure and I work out because I
like to look healthy I like to look
younger and maintain it but once you
start thinking that you can hack this
process or completely reverse this
process is where it fails no but you
feel you've slowed it down yeah you can
but it's not anti-aging what I think
that's semantics
I don't think so because those people
are looking to cure aging and I don't
think we need to cure aging Nobody Gets
Out Alive Well everybody's gonna die yes
so the idea of the testosterone dropping
let's focus on that because we talked
about trt earlier they would say after
the age of 30 35 your testosterone start
dropping one percent so some people will
recommend that you should start fixing
that and give yourself the testosterone
as if it never stop dropping that's
their idea of anti-aging I disagree I
think it's appropriate for a
testosterone to drop as you age
that's the philosophical difference do
you if you add the testosterone if
you've dropped the testosterone and then
you use testosterone and an additive do
you feel physically better
it's not proven
uh but you have uh when you add
testosterone uh you libido can change
yeah so you're saying energy levels the
cognitive issues those things that
people frequently want to take
testosterone replacement for with normal
testosterone levels
do not have not been proven to change by
taking trt
but you know what has been proven
increased risk of heart attacks of young
people taking testosterone replacement
therapy one unnecessary uh those folks
losing their ability to conceive
potentially for Life permanently uh
gonadal shrinking we're back
prostate cancer increases
well if you take any hormones that your
body isn't making on its own doesn't
that have increased risks in general it
can but if you are really low in those
hormones because of a disease State now
the benefits change remember again we're
going back to the benefits and risk
thing because you're so low in it you're
out of that normal we need to bring you
back to normal by giving you the hormone
but now giving you more boosting you
immune boosting energy boosting now
you're getting into a place of another
extreme where your body is not good now
you're going to get all the side effects
foreign
[Music]